with these television companies support
c-span 2 as a public service
and now on book tv more television for
serious readers
hey everybody this is jeff martin with
magic city books here in tulsa oklahoma
i'm so thrilled to have you joining us
for our ongoing virtual author event
series which we have been doing
for about 16 months and we've had the
great
privilege and pleasure of hosting
well over 160 plus author events in that
time and
talked to a lot of amazing people um
talk about a lot of great books and it's
been a great way to stay connected with
all of you too in this strange time and
keep it tethered to our audience but
also reach a lot of new people i know we
have a lot of people watching tonight
from outside of oklahoma maybe even
outside the country all over the country
uh thank you for joining us it really
means a lot to us that you would spend
some time
with us and
if you'd like to know more about
everything coming up we're going to keep
doing this virtual thing for a little
while but we are slowly transitioning
into some real in-person human beings
with human beings kind of events
later this month you can see that on our
website one thing of note i will mention
if you're in our area on july 13th next
week we're going to be doing an actual
in-person event with the united states
poet laureate joy harjo which should be
a really wonderful conversation that'll
be uh at all souls unitarian church here
in tulsa so you can get tickets for that
at our website
magiccitybooks.com don't miss that if
you have the chance to see it
um
tonight's event really excited for
tonight's event
also because i get to be an audience
member like you and watch two great
writers in conversation which is always
always a pleasure and always a thrill
our moderator for tonight
i first got to meet virtually last fall
when we did a uh event for a wonderful
novel called the water dancer if you
have not read ta-nehisi coates book the
water dancer i would certainly encourage
you to do so
um and that was a conversation we had
where tahasi was in conversation with
damon lindelof the creator of watchmen
and uh it was a really wonderful event
got to meet both of these gentlemen
virtually and actually got to bring
damon lindelof to tulsa a few weeks ago
for the centennial of the tulsa race
massacre with the writer core jefferson
who joined us as well we had a in-person
event here in the greenwood district
just a couple of blocks from our
bookstore and that was a great way so
without that event we probably wouldn't
have had that either so i want to say a
big welcome and thank you to our
moderator for this evening tadahassee
coats
and also our guest of honor who has just
dropped on the new york times bestseller
list i believe as of today
uh long-time writer for the atlantic and
creator of an article from 2018 that i
think will go down as one of the
signature pieces thought pieces of this
era that we live in i think the cruelty
is the point as a phrase that will go
down much like you know it's the economy
stupid or follow the money in our
history of political discourse as
something that defines an era and i was
so thrilled to see that the
piece that adam wrote for the atlantic
was being expanded and going a little
bit deeper into what he had to say about
this strange era that we are living in
so adam and tahasi are going to be in
conversation for about 40 45 minutes i
would encourage you all to ask some
questions in the q a and we'll pull some
of those
at the end as well and get to some of
those questions so please put those in
there and if you need more copies of
this book all of you thank you all for
buying a copy of the book everyone who's
watching got a copy of the cruelty is
the point but if you need some more for
your friends and your family and your
co-workers who need to have tough
conversations you can get a bunch of
those there at that link in the chat i
won't keep dropping that in there so
thank you all for watching and a big
thank you to mr tanahasi coats and our
guest adam serwer and i will turn it
over to you gentlemen to begin the
conversation
well thank you guys uh for having me
back this time in a row that's actually
probably a little bit more comfortable
as a moderator
it is
my
astute and complete and you know i don't
have enough adjectives and superlatives
to describe it but i guess i'll just
stop and say it's my honor to be here
with adam you know who's a good friend
of mine
um a right i admire and and and look up
to
uh in addition to that and um
now a new york times uh bestseller you
know congratulations adam it's not a
small thing
um
i want to uh uh
divide this conversation into two parts
um i i want to talk about the
implications of adam's book the
political implications of adam's book um
because i think there are many and i
think that they're profound and i think
there are implications that we don't uh
usually like to think about
and i want to talk about the
possibilities of political solutions or
whether they even are political
solutions and to begin with
um and then i want to talk about adam as
a writer uh because i i i you know
sometimes people see something like uh
or cruelty is the point uh phrase like
that and you know that that that phrase
went everywhere i'll talk to adam about
how you know he felt about that
but what people don't realize is um when
adam came up with that he was doing the
essential job of a writer which is to
distill to clarify folks see something
happening out in the world and not try
they're not not quite sure how to give
language to it and in in those short
words adam gave us language uh for what
we were actually seeing during the trump
era so adam if i if i could i'd just
like to start to
reading a very short excerpt from the
centerpiece of this book
out of cruelty is the point
it is not just that the perpetrators of
this cruelty enjoy it it is that they
enjoy it with one another
their shared life that the suffering of
others is an adhesive that binds them to
one another and to trump
taking joy in that suffering is more
human than most would like to admit
somewhere on the wide spectrum between
adolescent teasing and the smiling white
men and the lynching photographs are the
trump supporters whose community is
built by rejoicing in the anguish of
those who they see as unlike them who
are found in their shale cruelty in
answer to the loneliness and atomization
of modern life
it is that cruelty and and the delight
it brings them that binds trump's most
ardent supporters to him in shared scorn
for those they hate and fear
immigrants black voters feminists and
treasonous white men who empathize with
any of those who would steal their
birthright
the president's ability to execute that
cruelty through word and deed makes them
euphoric it makes them feel good it
makes them feel proud it makes them feel
happy it makes them feel united
and as long as he makes them feel that
way they will let him get away with
anything
no matter what it costs them
so i i i think those words you know uh
um stinging and clarifying and cold as
they are
um
offer a challenge to
uh
i would say contemporary liberal
discourse and maybe even broader than
that
about what happens in a politician and i
think there's you know a line running
through this book that talks at the
traditional notion uh and we saw this
with economic anxiety and then i'ma shut
up and ask the question
um was
i i think there was some comfort in the
idea that if you could just reward
people with things if you can make the
government quote unquote work or
function you know in in the daily lives
of americans voters would see that that
would reduce racism bigotry uh sexism
etc um what you are arguing
in this book really and in your work and
in that as i said in that center piece
is that no no that that's not actually
correct they enjoy the cruelty cruelty
is not a byproduct it's it's the point
and so
obviously that that kind of breaks
existing political
uh notions of how you address things and
so adam i i wonder
what we do when you have a portion of
your populace of your electorate that is
not there for for the social programs
that you know uh would indeed uh forego
the social programs if it meant somebody
else being punished
uh where cruelty is actually an ideal a
flag in which they unite around
what what is uh uh someone who wishes to
see a democracy
that responds to you know a broad
electorate it's supposed to do how do
you forge a country out of that
um well thank you tana hosley for that
kind introduction um i think
that you know what i'm talking about
really goes back to the founding of the
country
you know you have a country where you
say
all are created equal but you sever a
tremendous amount of the people from the
country to that ideal
um so
you know white men with pride it really
applies to white men with property it
doesn't apply to black people it doesn't
apply to the enslave it doesn't really
apply to women as they meant it at the
time
um and so to justify that you have to
come up with reasons for why
that
um you know these blessings that you say
are
are
the
um
the right of all humanity why a certain
segment of humanity uh is not entitled
to them
um and
you know this is a battle that we've
been fighting as a country since the
founding
you know we've plotted it during
reconstruction uh we plotted during the
civil rights movement and every year in
between
um and i think if you understand
that
america's
fragile experiment with multi-racial
democracy
only really started in earnest in 1965
then it becomes much more understandable
that it is
as vulnerable as it is
to this kind of ideology which after all
uh long predates
trump
um
you know
basically uh you know what we have a
situation where
the structure of our system allows one
party to hold power without winning a
majority of the votes
um
because of the ideal
geographic distribution of that group of
people
and so the party that represents that
group um it becomes even more agent
urgent for them to persuade them that
they are sort of on the verge of
annihilation their way of life is about
to be destroyed and you can see this
with donald trump in his rhetoric he
says you know i'm the one who's going to
protect you from everything
um you know i'm i'm gonna protect you
from what the liberals are going to do
when they gain power which is take
everything away from you that matters to
you
um and that's how you end up justifying
things like disenfranchising
constituencies
uh how you justify trying to violently
overthrow an election
um
it's all tied to this idea that there is
a you know legitimate group and there's
a group in america that has the
legitimate right to permanent political
and cultural hegemony in the united
states and anything that threatens that
is a threat to the country that as it is
meant to be
trump didn't invent that he didn't come
up with it it's as old as the country
itself but he was um
a talented practitioner of that kind of
politics
because he watched fox news every day
and repeated what he saw on fox news
back to these audience of these
audiences that's validating um the
things that they had come to believe
were responsible for all the problems in
their life um so it's not simply you
know to say that
economic struggle creates racism is
wrong because your struggle is mediated
through ideology
uh it's not you know you don't simply
come to conclusions um it's not like
we're not robots you don't type in a
program and it comes and you have a
particular reaction
um
what happens is your misfortunes your
problems are mediated through uh you
know the things the the values that you
have and what you have come to believe
about the way that the world works
now what's interesting i suppose is that
you know trump has never really
commanded a majority it again it's it's
reliant on
the counter-majoritarian levers of
american democracy in order to remain
viable
and that offers a kind of solution which
is that you have to make the system
which was designed to be unfair in many
ways uh to be more fair you have to make
a structural alteration to that system
because the only way that parties really
respond to
the only way they really change is by
responding to differences in their
ability to hold power and we know this
because you can look at the democratic
party which was once
the most
white supremacist organization in
american life um and
when
in 1932 uh beginning in 1932 when black
voters in the north uh began to become
part of the new deal coalition
that
um
that coalition the labor unions urban
liberals black voters
um they
changed the course of this party which
up until then was the party of racial
apartheid in the south
and that is tremendously powerful it
also offers a path forward and it tells
you
how you
um ultimately defeat this kind of
politics which is you have to make it
less rewarding
as long as they can win power doing the
stuff that they're doing right now
they're going to do it as long as they
can alter the rules to diminish the
influence
of
uh voters that they consider
illegitimate not truly american
they will continue to pursue that path
um and that's
you know on the one hand that's sort of
dark on the other hand you know this is
probably the first time in american
history
that the coalition that opposes that
ideology
is as big as it is
you know it wasn't this big during
reconstruction it wasn't this it wasn't
this big in 1968 when richard nixon uh
you know in the midst of the backlash
the civil rights movement
won
uh that election and then subsequently
won re-election that was a genuine
majority
you know what i mean like richard nixon
was not uh representing a ideally
geographically distributed minority of
american voters he actually had most
americans were on his side and trump
never really had
most americans on a side so i think
that's
a kind of you know
in some ways that's a
kind of thing that that's something
that's sort of hopeful
on the other hand you know as long as
this system
enhances the
political influence the most
conservative elements of the electorate
um you know there's no reason for the
republican party to change course from
where it's going right now
yeah it's like you go into a football
game and you spot the other team 10
points every time
yeah that's right
so
go ahead go ahead
no i was going to say what's interesting
is the fact that their power is actually
artificially enhanced
by the structure of our system
um
for some reason they don't
process that
as um you know because because of this
ideology where they consider themselves
to be the only legitimate inheritance of
the american tradition
they don't see that at as an unearned
advantage or as the unearned advantage
that it is
um
they in fact see the other side as
somehow taking advantage of things that
they are not entitled to
um when it's really that they are
um
you know their power is enhanced beyond
what it should actually be in a more
democratic system
you know so i just want to and then i
want to get back to the book but i just
want to play this out as as you
suggested which you seem to be pointing
to is the idea that needs to be you know
literal you know democratic reforms you
know there needs to be you know one
would you know look at at dc statehood
one would look at how the senate is
apportioned one would look every
district thing all the things that you
said that basically advantage
um the the um the audience uh for for
for this kind of cruelty
you have a political situation though
where um you know as your client argues
the thing that disciplines the
democratic party is actually is
diversity
uh that's right and and that's a good
thing
but part of that diversity is kristen
cinema and joe manchin right that's
right um so how do you even you know
what is the the prognosis not to turn
you into too much of a pundit
but
if you have a party
that a feeds off of that cruelty has an
unearned advantage from it and you have
another party that can't really unite
uh in opposition or in defense of
democracy thus far at least
um
where does that leave you long-term to
say nothing of the the entrenched
advantage of judges for instance also
so
the democratic party represents a
majority
but it does not have the unity of
purpose that comes with being a smaller
party and the republican party does not
represent a majority
but because of its homogeneity
racially religiously ideologically
it has a unity of purpose that the
democratic party doesn't have
um and i think
you know
i don't know really what the answer is
that your mansion and kristen's
cinema is because
um
you know it during reconstruction
republicans were not um
they were not ardent believers in racial
equality there were a couple of people
who were charles sumner um thaddeus
stevens but in general the party was
often on the defensive saying oh
political rights does not mean you know
you have to serve a black person in your
establishment or you have to let a black
person marry your daughter uh we're not
talking about that we're not talking
about social equality
and
um you know but they came to understand
i mean people think of the 14th and 15th
amendments as you know these great i
mean well both of us do anyway as these
great accomplishments but they were both
partisan and ideological accomplishments
the republican party had an ideological
interest
in defending the black vote because
the republican party was not viable in
the south without the black vote
and you know the democratic party is in
a similar position today to the extent
that
um you know
uh you know this is one of the reasons
why manchin's objection to sort of
partisan voting protections was sort of
ridiculous because
that's how we got the 14th and 15th
amendments
and if you are willing to seed veto
power
to people who to a 6-3 court that is
willing to write the 15th amendment out
of existence
when it comes to the rights of black
voters um and a party that simply sees
its interest in continuing to restrict
the electorate so that it does not have
to be responsive to a more diverse group
of voters
um
you know
at some point you have to decide
you have to decide whether
the
decorum of the senate is more important
than the fundamental rights of your
constituents
yeah
uh you know
[Music]
the democrats can't do that what you
know i'm not
i don't know that republican voting
restrictions will succeed in insulating
their power from the electorate that's
certainly what they're trying to do but
i don't know that that will actually
work
uh what i will say
is that if it does work
it's less likely that republican party
dominance lasts forever then democrats
will have to move considerably to the
right to compete in an artificially
conservative electorate that actually
does not reflect the majority of the
country
um and i think you know that is going to
have tremendous cause i mean when this
happened
in the 1870s
it had tremendous costs
for
uh black people in particular because
when you are no when you know in a
democrat the whole point of a democracy
is that politicians are responsible to
the people
and when you can take a certain group of
people and make it so that you no longer
have to be responsible to them because
you're disenfranchised then that opens
them up to
being mistreated and their rights uh not
being respected
uh and so if we get to that point with
these restrictions and again i'm not
sure that they're gonna work um that's a
very dangerous thing for the vulnerable
uh constituencies on which the
democratic party currently relies for
power and on whom you know
and these constituencies are reliant on
the democratic party to defend their
rights
um so
i don't want to make any predictions
because i
i just don't know what's going to happen
but i do think
um it's a very dangerous place to be
yeah yeah yeah you know and one of these
pieces in here you you um
went out adam adam is not just a comment
and a thing i love about adam adam one
of the things i love about him adam's
also a reporter i mean one of these
pieces i believe early actually on
uh maybe when trump was running you know
you actually went out and did some
reporting
um out in the field and so one of the
things that i i kept wondering i hope
hope that you might address here is
you talk about again in that centerpiece
i say this idea that we underestimate
the the appeal of cruelty we
underestimate
like it's not something we talk about
like you know you sit back and you watch
you know some pundits analyze why a
certain candidate did well no one says
you know none of pundits say well it was
because you know ted cruz was
particularly cruel tonight
you know it's not a particularly common
end so it's not it's not a way that we
like to think about ourselves
um but i wonder whether you yourself
have thought much about what the appeal
of cruelty actually is and not just
among americans but to groups of people
that you know in polity i think you know
if you look at you know orban for
instance you can see cruelty you know
certainly in in how how he's campaign
when you look at le pen you know you can
see and you know and to some extent
macron you know you can see you know the
usage of cruelty to appeal to people and
i i wonder if you could just talk a
little bit about
what the target group not the target of
the cruelty but i guess the target of
the message actually gets out of that
i think it makes them feel
as though they belong
it makes them feel powerful
um and it makes them feel above the
people
who are being acted upon so i mean the
the sort of de-politicized version of
this that i give people is like you know
if you've ever been a child
you've seen like the cool kids try to
make fun of the nerdy kid and maybe um
you know maybe you join in because you
want to be part of the cool kid group or
maybe you are one of the few rare few
who stick up for the kid who's getting
picked on um or maybe you simply stay
silent because you don't want to be
um the next target and
the
kids who are the cool kids who are
teasing the nerdy kid they have formed
the kind of community through that act
of both transgression you know they're
they're doing something that they're not
supposed to be doing um and they have
uh you know bonded with each other over
their
uh shared
um cruelty towards this person on the
outside and so what it does is it
creates an us and a dem and justifies
what the us does to them
um and it's not you know all human
beings are capable of this kind of
cruelty you know i don't wanna i i try
to emphasize this is not you know this
is not something that is just about
conservatives or just about the
republican party i can remember you know
when i was sitting in my house in texas
during the freeze
i'm like going through social media and
i can see these you know i'm scrolling
and i can see these
tweets from people who are like oh well
that's what you get for voting for
abbott shouldn't have voted for abbott
and for me
that was i mean look that kind of
cruelty the different this the the
distinction between that and what you
see at the trump level
is that
the democratic party by view of it by
virtue of its diversity cannot behave
that way towards the opposition
so when when california was having
rolling blackouts ted cruz was on
twitter talking about
california's failed state
when
texas was having its blackout in the
middle of the worst winter storm in 10
years
the governor of california was like
you know
best wishes to texas you know will help
however we can
that's not because democrats are more
virtuous is that because liberals are
better people inherently it is because
when you are reliant on a diverse
coalition
you will try to win people over rather
than using them um and that you know
this is we can look at that through
history we can see when the democratic
party was in that position and was
behaving with these sort of rituals of
cruelty in order to create hard lines
between their community and the one that
they wanted to exploit and
now we see that the republican party is
in a similar position and is behaving
with that kind of contempt towards human
beings who are outside of its coalition
so i don't think you know this is an
essential part of human nature and the
only way to prevent it from dominating
politics is to have a system that
diminishes the rewards for engaging in
it
i always thought it like uh catcalling
is like kind of an example of this um
where in you know uh a men forged
community
through dominance in public space that's
a great example yeah like they're almost
talking to each other as much as they're
you know what i mean making an example
it's almost not really you know they
don't think that woman is gonna respond
they are right
over her
right by humiliating her and then you
know showing their boys that they're you
know they're the kind of person who can
do this
right um so i mean that's a great
example
yeah yeah yeah
why do you think it is that uh
trump was so like like trump did not
like recently become racist you know i
mean it's marked his career
um since his entrance really into the
public consciousness you know from from
being sued off a housing discrimination
by the justice department yes up through
you know calling uh for uh the death
penalty uh for the central park five you
know through birtherism through you know
stuff in his in in in books written
about him et cetera this is not new
um
why do you think it was that
so many and it did you know they got to
a point where people were you know would
openly call trump races etcetera but i
guess my question is why why do you
think um folks have been so resistant
um to speak to the appeal of that
um to speak to that as an actual
political force as as you position as
opposed to a side dish
i think it is implicating i mean look
with you know white people are the
demographic majority in the united
states they
um also tend to be better off than other
demographic groups so they as consumers
they
hold a lot of power and for
you know if you are a mainstream outlet
a mainstream newspaper news channel um
you know
you don't want to alienate a huge
section of your audience and you know
tens of millions of people voted for
this man
um so
if that's the case you you really don't
want to avoid
alienate these people if you're a
democrat you might need some of them to
vote for you um if you're the new york
times you already have a bunch of
liberal readers you want to get these
people who do not currently trust you um
to listen to you and if you suggest that
racism has something to do with their
political choices
uh you're putting yourself in a position
to lose their money their trust
their viewership their readership
um and i think you know i believe i
believed for
at first
that because of this sort of market
incentive
that it was going to be very hard for
people to look this in the eye
um
and i think what happened was that
donald trump was so blunt and so
repetitive about what he believed
and why he believed it
and why he did the things he did that
instead of you know eventually people
just sort of had to accept that this was
what it was like when you're saying
corey booker is going to come into the
suburbs and threaten the housewives
i mean like you know it's so like on the
one hand it's like so old-timey racist
but on the other hand it's so absurd
that it lends itself to someone being
like hey
that's
over
and i think
you know i think uh
what's interesting is i think there's
not a lot of disagreement between me and
donald trump about what donald trump
believes and does there's disagreement
about whether that thing is good
right but there's not a lot of
disagreement
uh
between us about whether or not his
audience enjoys his cruelty towards
individuals
um whether or not you know race is a
is a part of his pitch to his voters i
mean i think he he said to the new york
times after he called kaepernick a a son
of a [ __ ] get that son of a [ __ ] off
the field
he he said you know my people love this
stuff he understands
exactly what he's doing
um and the
what
the disagreement i think really is
between
not between um me and donald trump or
donald trump and most of his left-wing
critics
it is between
those critics and the industry of people
in between
us and donald trump who want to
who like donald trump and want to
support him and want to tell themselves
that the things that we are describing
are not what they are supporting
um and so they have to say oh he didn't
mean it like that he he you know he he
was um he's not a politician he was
unpolished he was speaking off the cuff
this is a bad faith
liberal misinterpretation
of what donald trump said they're
smearing him it's fake news
whatever the rationalization
i think ultimately
donald trump and his worst critics his
most vociferous critics are in agreement
about what donald trump is about i think
the people who want to defend him are
the ones who are dissenting from that
consensus
so i want to shift the conversation a
little bit um
one of the things i i love about adam is
that he has great clarity
in his writing you know i was talking
about that at the top with the title um
that really is the job and adam i i
don't want to get you into too much
trouble here but um i certainly know you
know through conversations with you that
you have philosophies about how to write
um you know we've talked about this you
know there's a language for instance in
terms of activists and then there's a
language that you know i would say
somebody like you not all writers but
somebody like you that you know writes
and that's very different
um i i always like this portion of the
conversation because it's never the case
that you know you never have any writers
in the audience would you talk a little
bit about your philosophy
of writing what you're trying to do
um and and how you do it a little bit
yeah so um
i would say the past five years in
particular
there's a book called black
reconstruction in america by w.e.b du
bois
um and in in it he sort of says
you know at the time that he's writing
the
mainstream historical consensus is that
reconstruction was a tragic failed
thing it was corrupt uh it was uh you
know quote negro tyranny
it was a mistake to enfranchise black
men and therefore the jim crow system is
a moral and justified end to that
foolish experiment
and du bois writes in his book he's like
look this book
um
is for people who think that black
people are people
that they are just as um you know
capable
talented and flawed as other human
beings
and if you do not believe this you will
be unable to
read and understand this book
um and i'm not even trying to convince
you if you're that person what i'm
trying to do is write the truth
and for me you know i think it is very
tempting and i think there is an idea of
opinion journalists in general that our
role is to persuade people who don't
already agree with us to agree with us
now look it would be nice if that
happened
but i don't think that's my job i don't
think i think fundamentally my job is
actually you know similar to
objective journalists
in the sense
that my job is to write what's happening
as best i can so that the audience the
public can make a decision based on you
know whatever information they get from
me you know
that they
uh feel like is useful um i feel like my
job is to put down a record of events
that is as close to accurate as i can
get it um not to say
slant my argument in a way that i think
will
portray
persuade trump supporters to see it my
way um and i think if you do that you
ultimately end up
risking that you will be dishonest in
your argument because you want to be
persuasive
um it's it there's a possibility that
your argument becomes corrupted by your
desire to
appeal to
a hypothetical person who does not
already agree with you
um and whether you agree with me or not
what i am simply trying to do is
describe the
events as accurately as possible
um and you know obviously not everybody
feels that way but i feel like it's
important to approach the job that way
because it helps me
um it gives me a kind of clarity for
focusing on what i want to say
all right so i'm on now i'm going to use
that on my back up a little bit um
so what are there a lot of books in your
household
yes
a lot of
you know my father worked for the state
department my mother worked for the
smithsonian
um
um
that valued
that kind of learning and knowledge um
and were
you know i mean i can remember you know
uh my parents giving me you know
children's biographies of
malcolm x and muhammad ali when i was
like 60 years old
um and they didn't it's interesting
because they didn't necessarily tell me
what to think about those things but
they were clearly trying to shape my
understanding of the world
um and so yeah i grew up in a house with
a lot of books um and i was expected uh
to read a lot of books as a child
did you and did you enjoy it
at the time
um
you know
i did but i much preferred comic books
to the books that my parents wanted me
to read
of course
i was a you know a tremendous reader of
comic books more than anything else to
the point where
you know if my parents wanted to punish
me
they would come into my room and like
take all the comic books
and like shove them into a box and just
take them out and be like you get these
back when you like finish your homework
right you know
so
when do you when does the light switch
come on where you think what was the
first moment where you were like
oh i think i can do this like when you
go from reader to writer like when what
is the earliest moment you can remember
that
i started uh i started off writing bad
poetry on metro buses in washington dc
um
and
i think you know i i went to to vassar
uh college and i majored in english
where i was fortunate enough to have
um kyoce lehmann who was a great uh
novelist and memoirist as a
teacher
um and he was you know he was a very
important force in my life in terms of
um
making me think about how to be a writer
um
[Music]
and did he tell you did he tell you you
could do it like was he the first person
to say you you can actually do this
uh uh
kiese was
he was encouraging but he was not you
know
he he was
respectful of whatever it is that you
were trying to do with writing
and he would ask questions that were
meant to guide you in that direction
without telling you he didn't give you
answers
um
because i think his philosophy and and i
hope i'm not mistaking it but i think
his philosophy was
that he wanted to guide you towards the
type of writer that you wanted to be not
the writer that he thought you should or
that he might think you should be
and
you know originally i actually wanted to
make documentaries that was what i went
to the journalism school for um but i
was also blogging on the side and this
is this is dating myself
um
but uh it was it was um you know 2007
2008 which was sort of the late blog era
in sort of the amateur sense and that
was actually how we met which was uh i i
had been a reader of yours and i noticed
that you had a blog and you were you
were just trying your hand at blogging i
was like oh that's that's a ton of hatsu
codes
um
and and that's sort of how we originally
met was on the internet so you know your
internet friends are real everybody
right they are they are they can be
it can be
um but i don't i think you know i was
blogging and you know i had a decently
well-regarded blog among certain people
it wasn't like heavily trafficked or
anything um but
the american prospect asked me to guest
blog for them um as i was graduating
journalism school and i couldn't get any
jobs in documentary there are not a you
know those jobs are like you know in
public television or with certain
companies and are there not a lot of
them and they're hard to get
um and so i sort of
you know the american prospect job
seemed very appealing to me because it
was a chance to still retain my own
political voice
um and that's what i find so precious
about magazines in general
is that they allow you
to um
see with your eye
and one of the you know one of the
uh
another form of another medium that used
to do this and i only say used to
because they tragically are falling by
the wayside but um all weeklies were of
course like a wonderful training ground
for this kind you know you're a city
paper alumni
um you know
outlets like the village voice or the
riverside times like these outlets that
encourage you to both report
and
um
and be open about your personal
ideological perspective and views
were like to me that was um
that was the kind of journalism that
really appealed to me
um and so i was fortunate to start off
with the american prospect and was
fortunate to come into
uh you know a magazine that thought of
itself as an intellectual project um it
still does it's still a great magazine
um
and that was sort of
my
it was sort of a crooked path it was not
a very straight
um you know it was not like i woke up
one day and i said i wanted to be a
journalist and then i worked for the
school paper and it was sort of
accidental i just sort of tumbled into
it um and it turned out to be um
you know it turned out to be a rewarding
career for me
um and i'm fortunate in that way i mean
especially considering the state of the
industry
um it's very
you know
there aren't as many jobs as there used
to be and there are a lot of talented
people who don't have them um people who
are just as talented as i am or just in
a different situation um so i feel very
grateful to be where i am
you know
one of the things i think about when you
write and i'll make this a last question
because i believe it's about time for
our q a
uh one of the things i think about like
when i read your writing um
i feel like
um i'm gonna use a word that gets a bad
rap but i actually think it's very very
important
um
i can feel the emotion and
in a book like this i can actually feel
the anger i can feel you seething um
it's controlled
it's like bubbling and a pot it's not
overflowing it's not ruining everything
you know what i mean it's not overdone
you know but but but it's there just
kind of bubbling at the appropriate
level and i think what that does is um
you know i i teach a writing class up
here at nyu and i always tell my kids
that you know contrary to what you think
um you actually need heart you actually
have to put your heart
in something you know there has to be
some of you it doesn't mean it has to be
a first person piece
but but that feel there has to be a kind
of transference an energy that you feel
in yourself that has to you know get
conducted through your fingers into the
keyboard and i i wonder what which what
your rituals are do you have to calm
down you know obviously we have
conversations online about this sort of
thing or do you write when you're
feeling it or what do you do
um i find exercise to be very focusing i
run a lot um
i listen to music i mostly these days i
mostly listen to wordless music so i
have
um a jazz playlist that i often write to
that helps me focus um and i have um
a
very weird lo-fi beats um playlist that
i listen to
that is really just for me and is full
of like weird um lo-fi remixes of
songs that you you would not expect to
hear beats to
um
but i
i find um i find it's best to write in
the morning uh for me i think
at some point in college i could just
write at any time of the day and i could
sleep at any time of the day and i could
eat in any time of the day but the older
i get
it's harder for me and so i find
um
i find uh a lot of uh
comfort in sort of keeping my rituals
predictable
um and like having like specific times
of the day where i do specific things
um
but the number one thing that i always
have to do is always have to run and
there's a way in which like the
adrenaline from running
just really sort of greases the wheels
in your brain and really gets you
thinking about what you want to say and
how you want to say it
do you have to do it before or after
adam
before
i find it i'm i'm in a better place
after i run than if i try to write
beforehand
okay obviously i could be here all day
but jeff go ahead
yes we do have quite a few questions
from our audience so we'll get to a few
of those um and i think some of them are
directed at both of our guests tonight
uh so you can take this whoever would
like to jump on that question but
um i'd like to begin with a question
from one of our viewers named paul who
says um
so apropos with like the you know trump
announcing lawsuits against the social
media companies today uh you know how
can social media be held accountable for
its collective role in the promotion of
cruelty
yeah i mean i i don't know
the answer that question i i would say
that you know there's something to the
premise i think um
social media thrives on conflict um and
it has certainly incentivized a
particular kind of conflict
between people where we are as
uncharitable as possible to each other
in contesting
arguments
um i don't know what the solution to
that is
um i don't
you know you can't
uh we have a first amendment you can't
like force um
private companies to
use algorithms that uh reward conflict
less
um i suppose
the only
way to do that would simply to be to
leave the platforms in the first place
and that's what you know that's what
ta-nehisi did
um
you know which i you know a decision
that i respect and admire um but i think
you know to the extent that we have a
power the power to um
change that is by telling the platforms
um as consumers that that's not what we
want
one of our viewers laura says
do you have any recommendations for ways
to engage with trump supporters and hold
a mirror to their actions so that they
can accurately see their reflection
um
i
don't think there's like a special way
like trump supporters are people
um they're people you disagree with and
so you know i don't really have there's
no like magic way to get someone who you
disagree with to
agree with you uh you just approach them
the way you approach anybody else you
disagree with and tell them why to the
extent that you know that is even
to the extent that it's appropriate to
do that i mean i'm not recommending
anybody run up and like start arguments
with strangers uh you know unfortunately
united states is a very dangerous
activity um but
uh you know i really think you know it's
like anything else i mean
to some extent you know
disagreement is part of a democracy the
purpose of democracy is to
resolve conflicts without bloodshed it
is not to have
no conflict at all we're always going to
have political political disagreements
there's always going to be people who
have conservative views
on religion on immigration on economics
um
and i think
one thing we should do in general is
understand that we are never going to
live in a world without disagreement and
we actually would not want to
um
you know my objection to trumpism is not
that they disagree with me it is that
their disagreements
have led them to a place where they are
attempting to
change the political system so that they
are no longer accountable to the people
who disagree with them politically um by
severing them from the franchise or
diminishing their political power to the
extent that they are no longer able to
fully participate equally in our
political system um we are we
we're always going to have disagreement
and and democracy is the means to
resolve those disagreements um but it
can't do that
uh if we don't respect it
um
matthew is asking uh this is a question
that adam you touched on but i think
certainly applies to both of you um it
feels like many individuals with comic
book reading backgrounds are those
speaking and writing with the most moral
clarity in the trump era
do you have comics that were important
to you and helped your moral
understanding
oh man this is going to get a little
weird uh my favorite comic book
character is superman i love superman to
death i think that there is um
i've been hearing a lot about this so
much that's
yeah
i think there's so much that's
interesting about a character who is as
powerful as superman is and still
decides consciously
to
use his power in a way
to help people but not to
gain dominion over the earth as you know
and there's
superman is so baffling to people in
this way that you see comic book writers
constantly trying to reimagine superman
as the evil dictator they assume someone
right they assume someone with that kind
of power would be but what's interesting
about superman is why he does not make
those decisions
um and i think you know just as an
artifact
of jewish american culture he's
fascinating i mean you know
everything from the the destruction of
krypton to the idea of
you know
an alien assimilating into american life
through a farm in kansas but yet still
remaining apart from american society
um i think uh
you know comic books are are folk tales
i mean and obviously we have american
folk tales that are not comic books but
i think there is um
a shared moral universe there that
uh
you know is precious
obviously you know i don't want to um
i can understand why some people are
saturated by or are tired of being
saturated by its commercial
ubiquity
um
but
uh
as a young
person when i was growing up i found
comics to be
often a wonderful
way to explore
moral complexity
and how to be good
even in a situation where you have the
ability to not be good at all
um and so for that i mean i can't speak
for anybody else but uh that's you know
that was my attraction to comic books
yeah
people don't know this we're gonna spend
the last 10 minutes talking about the
snyder cut so if anybody wants to cut
out now or not
um so i think i think ta-nehisi is
contractually prohibited from talking
about the schneiderkind i don't think
he's allowed to do that you're trying to
get him in trouble
um
this is a question um
from nicholas who says how can people
who want to help create the structural
change you talk about take steps to help
the system as it is can make one feel
powerless where should we start and put
our energy
um look i perfectly understand why you
would ask this question
i am not the person to answer it um
you know these are this is a kind of
question you know whenever people are
like well you know what can the
democrats do or what can liberals do or
something like that i'm not a political
strategist i'm not an activist
i do not know
these steps to creating the world a
better or more just world
i can describe the world that we're in
and why we're in it and that's what i
feel like my role is
but
in terms of um you know changing the
world for the better there are a lot of
wonderful brilliant
people who are working on that and who
would be better people to address that
kind of question too
you know
um
final question is this
you know we just celebrated juneteenth
around the country of course everyone
knows
it was just made into a federal holiday
which has been you know commented on
from many different sides um last year
on juneteenth here in tulsa in the midst
of the pandemic was raging and of course
um you know in weeks after george
floyd's murder trump decided to host his
first rally on juneteenth here in the
city of tulsa just a few blocks or from
our shop here which in and of itself
before he before they changed it was a
very uh to most um cruel acts you know
choosing that day and of course there
were is that the one herman cain came to
yeah herman cain died right after that
um right after that um and so
that moment and of course they changed
it to the day afterwards and then trump
said you know he helped you know no one
had heard about juneteenth until he
helped make it famous all that stuff
that happened after that but that moment
of him and his crew choosing that day
right on there was a very overt act to
me of example of cruelty and using kind
of that strategy you talk about um and
then of course one year later we're in a
very different place where the
celebration of juneteenth here in tulsa
one year later was a very much different
thing i asked you this
do you feel like
in that one year time you see a lot of
progression is this an anomaly are we
feeling like things are getting better
quickly and also
that moment specifically
do you see that as kind of an example of
the larger kind of trump team
somewhat subtle way of doing cruel cruel
acts
on a um subversive level it's a big
question but
so as long as we're talking about tulsa
i just want to shout out uh viola ford
fletcher hughes van ellis uh leslie
benning phil randall the the the
remaining survivors of the tulsa
massacre who of course you know
testified before congress
um
um
is
uh very precious that we still have
their witness
to those events um to rely on and to
learn from
um
i think that trump excelled at
provocation uh not simply uh you know
as
as an act of cruelty but in general
making people mad
and i think that that ability to make
people mad
was a source of pleasure
um for many of his supporters uh
especially if they felt like
the provocation
[Music]
even if the provocation was deliberate
if they felt the reaction was
unjustified or exaggerated
the uh the more they enjoyed it um and
and i think you know whether or not it
was cruel you know whether or not trump
even understood what he was doing and to
be honest in that particular instance
i'm not sure
that trump understood the significance
of juneteenth or the significance of
having the rally
at that time
um
[Music]
he
enjoys provoking people
as part of how he
monopolizes
the economy of attention that is so
precious in politics
um
and that i mean that was an example of
it
uh and you know he
will continue to use that skill to keep
himself relevant whether or not
he
pursues the presidency again
the book is the cruelty is the point all
of you have a copy of it i'm sure many
of you have dived into it already it's
going to be i think one of the
most important books of the year in a
conversation that you want to that you
want to be part of so uh i hope you all
will spend some time reading that over
the this in the coming days um i want to
say a big thank you to
tahasi coats and also congratulations on
your new gig at howard university very
excited to hear about that and of course
to our special guest adam serwer new
york times bestseller much deserved i
hope you both
are well and we will hope to talk to you
down the road thank you gentlemen for
your time thank you for having us
thank you all
right thank you very much take care
everybody